one of the fastest ways to change your
habits and your physique
is to change your environment this is
why creating your own space
somewhere you can get away from it all
and either train or focus on work
can be such a powerful tool for
enhancing
any aspect of your self-development
having a home office somewhere you can
just focus on work
somewhere that is surrounded by things
that inspire you and tools that you use
to work better
is a brilliant way to prime yourself to
get yourself in the right mood to be
productive and i'm not just talking
about people who work from home
although there's many more of those than
they were ever before right now
i'm talking about anyone who wants to
work on a side project who has
other things they want to pursue whether
it's a novel or creative endeavor
somewhere quiet that provokes work and
productivity can be a huge asset
and likewise having someone to train in
your own home
can make a massive difference to your
success all of a sudden you'd have to
make a commute to get to the gym you
don't have to
queue for the squat rack and you don't
have to feel self-conscious doing
unusual things that you feel other
people might judge
now you can train whenever you feel like
it throughout the day and that way
become a better mover not just someone
who trains but someone who is
more active and who uses their body
throughout the day this is why i think
everybody can benefit from creating
their own bat caves
so i covered this topic once before on
the channel a couple of years back
and you guys submitted some of your own
home batcaves some of the places where
you train
and where you work and so i thought we'd
do it again a few years later my own
office and home gym have both changed
over the years so i thought i'd share
with you some of the
upgrades and my changing philosophy on
that and likewise i thought now we've
got a bigger
audience we'd have more cool places to
work out
to look at and let me tell you some of
you guys training some really awesome
setups
so hopefully we'll be able to pick up
some tips from one another to get some
inspiration
but don't feel like you can't join in if
you have a small space in fact as you'll
see
i and many others are making do with
unideal spaces you don't have to be
bruce wayne and
live in a manner with heaps of cash to
make this work
like i like to say there's no such thing
as a lack of resources
only a lack of resourcefulness
i call my home office gym the bio lab
because i'm a massive nerd this room is
also a guest room so i've had to
accommodate a big safer bed
that said the sofa actually provides a
handy place to sit and read
and a great spot to do some dips
the brains of the operation is the bio
computer that's a pretty new aurora r11
packing a 16 core ryzen 9 3 950 x
an rtx 3080 64 gigabytes of ram and
three terabytes of storage
that's by far the most specked out
computer i've ever owned
but it has already proven to be a smart
investment for how much more quickly i'm
able to edit
render and create 3d animations and yeah
it games pretty good too
i work on two monitors which is now
pretty hard to go back from
i have one fancy 1440p monitor and a
small cheap monitor to one side
i recently also got myself a secret lab
chair it's really comfortable and so far
seems to be much better for my back than
the old
20 quid chair i had from argos i kept
that thing for like five years
the result is a workspace that's
extremely comfortable and i actually
enjoy sitting down in
this is really important if you want to
be productive you want to look forward
to sitting down to write or edit with a
cup of coffee
and that way it doesn't feel like a
chore you'll make more time for it
it also means that when you're there
you'll feel better and you'll put out
better quality work
to further this course i've filled the
room with things that inspire me or help
create the right mood
i've got my first ever iron man comics
on the wall a bit of nostalgia there
a batman disc plate which is a recent
addition and a picture that i created
that you can actually buy if you like
the links should be in the description
right down below creating your own art
is a big win in my opinion as it allows
you to really customize your space i
have a chart of the muscular system on
the door too
this both sets the mood and serves as a
useful reference
when i inevitably forget the name of
that tiny muscle in the forearm
or you know the biceps i've also got an
echo here which can turn on my pc
see my old video for android authority
if you want to know how to set that up
and some hue lights which are overpriced
but do a great job
this way i can set scenes to match my
mood bright lights when i want to
concentrate or a light blue for working
into the evening
i also use these for background lighting
and youtube videos now
otherwise there's a star globe some old
vr headsets
some figurines figurines mum not toys
oh and lots of books which also serve as
a reference when writing a lot of this
stuff i've run out of shelf space which
they have to share with my action films
collection
and my graphic novels i also like to
work with music mostly synthwave which i
listen to on some jabra elite
85 h headphones i mentioned this last
time
but in his book deep work author cal
newport discusses the notion of a eu
demonia machine
this is a hypothetical space designed to
encourage the maximum inspiration
and productivity from an individual by
priming their mood
what this book doesn't really touch on
though is just how subjective this
should be
but i encourage you to make this space
yours rather than turning it into what
you think it should be
but this space is also a kind of mini
secondary gym for me
and it all comes back to what i describe
as incidental training
so incidental training is the term that
i use to describe training throughout
the day
whenever you stop what you're doing for
10 minutes to do a few reps of something
or to stretch that's incidental training
likewise when you curl your shopping as
you carry it back to the car
that's incidental training turning
everyday tasks into a form of training
to encourage this i've filled my office
with training tools and opportunities
for movement
i have dip bars that i can use at any
point to do dips as well as bodyweight
rows
and all kinds of other things i also
have some lower wooden parallettes for
hand balancing there's a balancing board
which is great for improving
proprioception
as well as waking up the brain in
general i also like using a bull worker
which is a device for isometric training
and that's perfect for working out in a
limited space because you're
not moving whether i'm practicing tuck
planche push-ups
banging out bodyweight rows or having a
juggle i'm up and doing something
multiple times throughout the day
and it's helped immensely with my
progress and so i give you the
bio arena this is where i come outside
to train and
i normally wouldn't get everything out
like this all at once i do occasionally
and it's really awesome when i do but
it's quite a lot of faff so instead i'll
just get out the pieces that i need
and use them on an as needed basis and i
put everything that i'm not using back
in the shed
a lot of it looks pretty scruffy and
rusty and that's because i love it i
just leave
outside here so i can pick it up
whenever i want it so there's zero
minimum friction between getting outside
and starting training
and a lot of people have commented that
that's kind of gross but the way i see
it
is i'd rather have a weight that looks
rusty that i actually use
and a pristine weight in the shed that i
never touch so i've acquired quite a lot
of junk
over the years but i've been training
for like 15 years and a lot of it no
surprise
can fall into the category of functional
training tools that means your sandbags
your kettlebells your
medicine balls and this is something
that you don't see that often in home
gyms you see a lot of people with
dumbbells of course
pull up bars and door frames etc but you
don't tend to see that many sandbags and
medicine balls i think the obvious
reason for this is that most people
train actually in their house and
there's not much you can do with a
medicine ball in the house
if you value any of your possessions and
so they're limited in terms of the
amount they can move
but this kind of defeats the whole point
of training in my opinion you want to be
moving you want to be explosive you want
to be exerting power
so moving outside train i think is
actually
far superior in a great number of cases
you just need a garden and a shed
and then you're good to go and you guys
have probably also seen that i sometimes
take this stuff to a field somewhere or
a nice scenic spot and i chuck it around
over there as well it's just great to
get moving
to be explosive and to not worry about
limited space
probably the centerpiece of this bio
arena however
is the pull-up bar that's mounted to the
wall and that's what i get the most
questions about
obviously having a pull-up bar that's
matched to a wall instead of fitted in a
door frame
gives you more opportunity to add weight
to throw yourself around
not worry about a destroying your door
frame or b it falling out and you
breaking your neck and actually knew a
guy who fell from a pull up bar upside
down
and he says it hurt quite a lot
i also have this eyelet here and two
more right there
and what that means is that using a
carabiner i can then attach all kinds of
other implements and you don't have to
be a fantastic martial artist to benefit
from a
punch bag obviously i'm not hitting a
punch bag is actually a fantastic form
of endurance cardio it's great to burn
calories to build strength and endurance
in the
pecs the triceps the shoulders the core
it can improve proprioceptions you learn
to move your body in a more
cohesive manner it can even improve your
mobility if you're throwing in some
kicks there as well
grant recently uploaded a video on this
channel discussing how to correctly use
a punch bag if you want to improve your
martial arts technique
and i highly recommend checking that out
if you want some pointers i love
my sandbag and i use it all the time one
of the reasons for this is simply
that a sandbag is soft which means it's
not that easy to hurt yourself with it
you can move
a lot more confidently you can sling it
around you can drag it on the ground
and you don't have to worry that you're
gonna knock your teeth out you can also
experiment with movements that you're
not confident with yet
at the same time though a sandbag is
also fantastic because it's a form of
unaccommodating resistance this
basically means that the weight shifts
around inside the bag every time you
perform the movement
so every time you perform the movement
it's slightly different and this builds
what nikolai bernstein
would refer to as more robust mental
models
basically what that means is that whilst
if you want to have perfect form on a
movement like the snatch or the clean
you need to perform it as near to
identically every single time so you can
rehearse those neural pathways if you
want that movement to then
transfer over to real world functional
strength then you also need to be able
to perform it
on an uneven surface you need to lift
awkward shapes
and this way you can actually use it in
the real world when you aren't presented
with a perfectly flat bar on a perfectly
flat ground with plenty of time
to get into the perfect position the
plyo box is also one of my
favorites and this is once again
something that's not that expensive
and that opens up tons of cool
opportunities but of course you can jump
onto literally anything it could be a
crate or someone suggested a water
barrel which can then also double as a
kind of
almost like an atlas stone another
somewhat hidden gem is this
a bulgarian bag and basically
this is a weirdly shaped sandbag it's a
similar soft material
canvas and you hold it from these straps
and basically what you do
is you spin it around your body like
that and it's literally called
a bulgarian bag spin i must admit i
don't use it as often as like the
sandbag or the medicine ball because
it's not quite as versatile but if you
want something really specific that
builds
strength endurance rotational power grip
strength
then the bulgarian bag is your boy and
it's not too expensive
okay guys now it's your turn bioneers
assemble so first up is greg parker a
returning participant with his awesome
home office and gym
as before i love the sheer number of
books in here in the front garden he has
an observatory just an awesome monument
to physical and mental development
miles hudlo aka upgraded dragon has
another awesome space i'd love to train
and work in
and his own plaque he calls this space
the dragon lab which is just really cool
and i love in general that you guys have
names for your bat caves too
now this is epic training with a view
like that in a dedicated space
is a dream love the selection of tools
and also the extremely stoic dog who
appears to be
very well trained to guard the area aj
nadal has these fantastic grips on the
ceiling for
ninja warrior style training
ernesto has been away from his usual gym
but has managed to come up with this
cool doorway set up in the meantime
curtis cameron has about the most decked
out home gym i've ever seen
the body boss portable gym looks really
interesting it lets you attach your
resistance bands to the ground
next up is dax who'll explain his home
gym in japan in his own words
hey how's it going i'm dax and this is
my home setup
i have a tension bar set up right in the
front entrance in the hallway of my
house my
setup my simple setup but this is kind
of the way i like it
i have the puzzle mats on the floor two
tens
with the fat grips on them for grip
strength
i have an array of bands these are the
jc bands from
jc santana's ihp
these are a beast these aren't like any
bands i've ever used before
while all these spaces have been awesome
so far i think jai's gym here has to be
the place i'd most like to train in
it's ninja warrior style again and it
looks like a playground which is exactly
how i think a great training space
should look
i also always approve of a slack line
the flynn jungle gym combines
traditional weight training with some
macgyver looking contraptions and a
really awesome set of monkey bars across
some scaffolding
i just love that you guys are training
like this you're like me
likewise landon brock has gymnastics
rings and a rope on the ceiling
and henrikh verkuel has this immense
all-in-one station
next up is the forge from dave kyuk i'd
happily join him for a stage i call this
room
the forge because this is where i like
to forge my own body
um it's a little cheesy and you got here
the kettlebells there's a slam ball back
there
jump ropes for me and the kids of course
and this is where i like to come down
unwind and have a cigar once in a while
um over here you got the rig with a
punching bag
i got the rings too i take the bag down
when i need to do some ring work
or some work with uh on the chin up bar
my work station this is where pretty
much the magic happens that's my website
singular reflections virtus kashal sorry
if i'm butchering the names here
has a bunch of maps and some phone boxes
to jump on which i love
and now i'm just going to roll a few
more whilst i chat the response has been
phenomenal so i'm sorry i couldn't talk
about all of them
thank you so much to all of you for
sending in your training and workspaces
it was really humbling that you all took
part especially those of you who filmed
as well
i'm really sorry if it took me a while
to respond or if i missed your gym
this honestly turned into a much bigger
project than i expected
don't worry i'm sure we'll do this again
i found this
mega inspiring seeing you guys training
this way with such creative uses of your
spaces
big and small just motivates me to want
to keep experimenting
i'd love to see some more submissions
from any female viewers in future
i think i need to expand my appeal
[Music]
i hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around
that helps me out immensely likewise
subscribe if you want more like this
and hit the bell button for
notifications it's too late of course to
be featured in this video but that
doesn't mean that you can't still submit
your own home batcaves over on the
facebook page i'd love to see them and
i'm sure others would as well and if
there's enough of a response maybe i'll
make a third one of these videos
if you like this approach to training
that improves your functional real world
performance
you can check out my ebook and training
program super functional training
the links in the description down below
there's a discount on right now whilst
ruling lockdown
that aims to improve everything from
mobility to strength to even iq
and all at once in a single cohesive
program alternatively you can check out
my print book functional training and
beyond
which serves as an introduction to this
topic with loads of cool examples of
real world performance either way thank
you so much for watching this one guys
and i'll see you next time
bye for now